كلمه واحده يمكن ان تشرح لنا كثيرا مما
يجري في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الان وهي كلمه
ديطانت ودي طانت الكلمه في العلاقات
الدوليه معناها تحسن العلاقات بين الدول
المتحاربه او المتخاصبه ظهرت ديطان او
تحسن العاقات في اقل صوره بعد تحسن
العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه ومحاوله
اعاده سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه مره
اخرى وسبقهما تحسين تركيا لكثير من
علاقاتها المضطربه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ليه الدول بتلجا الان الى الديطان ده او
تحسين العلاقات ببساطه لانهم جربوا في
غياب الولايات المتحده المواجهه ولم تفلح
والان ادركوا انه لا سبيل للتعاوش فيه ما
بينهم الا بتهدئه الاضطرابات ومحاوله
تجاوز خلافاتهم هل هذا الديطانت يعني اننا
امام فتره طويله من السلام والوئام ابدا
ادي طنطا ايضا فتره مؤقده قد يعقبها
اضطرابات وفوضى في منطقه الشرق